and even that like
that is like um
you know there was a lot of good if you
want a family you can have a family you
don't necessarily have to have your own
kids yeah but it's not really practical
for the average person I don't know how
much money you make
um so if you wanted to like freeze your
eggs and have kids like that that's a
good and also adoption isn't cheap you
probably need like 20 grand to do that
like my parents adopted three kids
so it's actually
um yeah it's not an easy process no no
so yeah so for the average person it's
not really like it's only if you want it
bad well pregnancy isn't having a family
that's it it's not cheap it's not easy
but pregnancy like it's definitely
cheaper than both of those options yeah
if you want a family bad enough yeah
finances and that's that's the reason
why I can't have a family because I'm
like
financially like that's I'm like no but
if I wanted it enough like I'd make it
happen I don't prioritize it do you ever
um so going back to like the body count
thing it doesn't matter to you do you
judge men if they care about it
like do you think they have a right to
want what they want
um
I so I'm yeah opinionated but
non-judgmental so I'm like you know just
because I won't feel the same way as
they do I'm like I understand why
someone's point of view is that point of
view like it doesn't mean that I don't
feel [ __ ] about it like if a guy a guy
once was like I said to him I was like
oh I've done casual dating I've done
casual sex and it's like that's really
unattractive and what hurt me most is
that I was like well you didn't give me
a chance to say like
of what I am now like you've judged me
on like my past yeah but we judge a man
on their past so yeah so if a guy said I
was unemployed for the last three years
we would probably judge him yeah yeah
and then I she was just like oh do you
know what like does it really matter is
this gonna matter when am I gonna cry
about this in two years time who who is
this man right yeah I mean that you're
not committed to who cares I I
understand like his opinion doesn't mean
I literally had a single conversation
with as well and he was like it's not
attractive to me that you've done casual
dating casual sex he was like have you
ever had a one night stand I was like
yeah I have and he was like that's
really unattractive and block me and I
was just at first like my ego my
self-esteem was a bit like what the [ __ ]
and then I was like okay but you've told
me that you go on a lot of dates right
but it's a double standard oh yeah yeah
yeah so I I do think like men have the
right to judge us for that and I don't
think like women we could say we judge
men for it but it's just not true like
women it's um I mean you probably know
it's psychology pre-selection yeah so if
a man gets a lot of women like
historically he he would have been able
to like take care of a lot of women so
it's attractive to us and we can't on
biology right we are how we are even if
it's unpractical in this day this is
like Animal Kingdom um which is really
funny um so you've got like in the
animal kingdom if the Lions the male
lions have got the big Mane It's the
male peacock and there's liar Birds it's
the males who show off all of their uh
vocals it's ah there's a bird I can't
remember it's like a little Robin but
it's the men and they literally like
create a nest and the woman so a lot of
it is the female selection yes yes
um and I think in humans it's become a
bit like it's it's uh there's no back of
whites obviously in humans I think it's
the same thing the only difference is
that how we show our worth as males is
you know if we take the advantage points
that we know that women are attracted to
successful men we go oh look at my house
look at my car yeah the lifestyle that
I'm living that is all that's all the
same as peacocking basically for for
guys I would say
yeah
but success is also very subjective and
it also depends on like what it's not
subjective I don't know because your
income is like very very data driven but
I would rather have a man that knows
about the ego and has been through
therapy and is like really healthy than
a man that's like so I've dated a girl
would you have you dated have you dated
a broke guy yeah yeah okay
so why aren't you with them
um oh because of that what were you
talking about before the show
you broke up with him why
um
they should know his money his ambition
yeah ambition and his inability to
believe in himself and make what yeah
I grew up like when I I grew up in
poverty yeah I understand I've I've
dated some very well like a guy that had
a lot of money but like didn't didn't do
much so I understand what you're saying
but we can't we can't act like money is
nothing I'd rather make my own money you
know Neo is Miss Independent like yeah
she walked like like she she wants a man
to see him I am so ferociously like I am
gonna have my own mortgage I'm gonna
have my own like I'm gonna be that [ __ ]
that's like I've secretly got money on
the side so if you want to leave me if
you want to cheat on me I'll be good
that's such a fear mindset oh yeah yeah
do you think decisions made out of fear
are good decisions
don't know I do I make good decisions
I've ever I have a question do you think
that the reason you don't care about
right now how much a man makes is
because you're not looking to have kids
right now you're not looking to settle
down but if you were if you got to a
point where like look I want to have a
couple of kids and you know as the woman
you're the one who Bears the children
right you're the one who has to tend to
take time off work so you're gonna need
a man who can provide for you if you're
gonna have at least a reasonable
comfortable life to have kids so do you
think that the reason that you don't
care about having kids right now or you
don't care about whether a guy is broke
is because you're not going to settle
down whereas if you did you would care
what 100 and that's why like when I said
that if I had kids I'd want to be
financially responsible I want to be
um so 100 yeah like I agree with that
because being selfish means that I can
be self-sufficient but yeah if I had
kids and I'm a very big I care more
about other people than myself so I'm
like if I've got me that's good that's
cool but if I'm having kids and
especially like if you're and yeah again
my own history my dad was a piece of
[ __ ] and could not Finance you before I
did all that kind of stuff but um yeah
like if if I was gonna plan on having
kids with a guy I'd be like yeah no like
I need to know that you can provide so
yeah it would definitely make a
difference if I wanted to have kids and
if that was where I was at 100 yeah so
then if we can all agree that we do
agree that most women want kids at some
point yeah yeah so that means most women
will always care about how much a man
will make always regardless how
independent she is regardless of where
she sits on the political Spectrum
whether she's conservative or liberal
whatever if a woman wants to have kids
with a man and she wants to build a
family she will always care to some
degree about how much he can make
I think the only anomaly that I would
have to take nod to is there are some
women who choose to have kids like on
their own who choose to like have
they're like do you think that's wise
when again we need 2.5 million to retire
in I don't know what it is here but it's
the average income for a woman is 25 000
in the US I'm gonna be really awful here
and I'm gonna be like I think that's a
bit selfish
okay no I agree yeah I agree unless it's
a woman who is like I'm very comfortable
I know I can give a kid
to incomes worth like you know single
like my mom is technically a single
pirate like shout out to her but that's
it I've seen what it's done to her it's
literally ruined her to be like I can't
help you with a mortgage I can't help
you with a marriage I can't help you
with XYZ
and that's the reason that she is like
hey don't have kids because
as many of you know
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible